[Music]
you've heard the benefits of
implementing a decision management
solution by capturing automating and
managing repeatable rules based business
decisions you can gain greater speed and
consistency become more responsive and
even anticipate future conditions
although you want all that value you
wonder if your organization can afford
such a solution
considering the skills and capital
expenditures required to design set up
and maintain the infrastructure you also
want to start benefiting from the
decision automation capabilities right
away to remain competitive in your
business environment that is
continuously moving ahead that
collaborative role based service is
completely in the cloud meaning you can
get started immediately without any
capital expenditures you can easily stay
up to date scale and adapt is needed and
achieve a faster time to value leave
operations management to IBM so you can
focus on automating your business
decisions delivering adaptable
applications faster and doing what you
do best drive your operations visit our
website to learn more